welcome to the Daily climate show coming
up today
decision imminence the governance is due
to announce whether a new Coal Mine in
cumbrian Countryside is given the
go-ahead despite the environmental
concerns
Humanity has become a weapon of mass
extinction the head of the un's warning
as biodiversity Summit cop 15 gets
underway
despite fracking being banned in the UK
richest tunak does a deal with Joe Biden
to ramp up Imports of U.S gas produced
by the process
hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes to our
world and investigate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis a decision is imminent on whether
the government will give the go-ahead to
the first UK coal mine in the generation
the proposed new mine outside New Haven
in Cumbria would produce coke and coal a
product on which the UK has been heavily
reliant on Russian Imports but the
prospects of opening a new coal mine has
of course proved controversial not only
with environmental campaigners but also
with conservative MPS given the
government's Net Zero targets
a West Cumbria mining plans for a new
mine was initially approved by the local
Council back in October 2020 but that
decision was later withdrawn and has
been subject to a public inquiry since
September 2021.
a mine is intended to provide coke and
coal for use in the still-making
industry rather than call for power and
is forecast to produce a total of 65
million tons of meteorological coal
now over its intended lifetime that will
be from 2028 to 2049.
environmental groups and many MPS have
opposed the plans including Alex Sharma
whom if you remember was president of
cop 26 who described them as a backward
step for UK climate action but the
mining company argues that domestic
production of metallurgical coal which
supports the steel industry reduces
shipping emissions from imported coal
and so has a much enhanced overall
carbon footprint our science editor Tom
Clark has the latest now from the site
of that proposed mine
the proposed West Cumbria coal mine
would stretch way out underneath the
Irish sea producing about three million
tons of coal to be used for coking
that's the raw ingredient for making
high quality steel
um every year and proponents of the mine
in this local area and there are many
supporters it's been successively
supported by the County Council and the
local Council here in Cumbia argue that
the 500 jobs it would create are much
needed for this community a community
that's effectively been left behind any
big employer in town is the seller field
nuclear power plant just further up the
coast
and that's the base of support and one
of the reasons the government may decide
to give the mine the go ahead this is
part of a leveling up agenda to try and
support jobs and communities in less
privileged parts of the UK
if they did make a decision to support
it it would raise profound questions
about their commitments to The Net Zero
agenda according to their own climate
change advisors the committee on climate
change emissions from the steel industry
have to be close to Zero by 2035 so if
this mine was to open and operate it
wouldn't be able to do that for very
long according to that advice it also
sends a very
mixed message internationally you saw
our leader stand up at the Glasgow
Summit in uh last year and at Egypt uh
cop 27 this year I made more
pronouncements about how we want to see
an end to Cole opening up a new Coal
Mine obviously works directly against
that the catch however is if the
government did decide to go ahead
understandably and say because of our
Net Zero targets we simply can't have
this mine open it does raise questions
about what that means for jobs in places
like this if it's no to 500 coal mining
jobs where are the green jobs to replace
them I think that's what people were
left asking if the decision goes against
the West Cumbria coal mine
a sign said he said Tom Clark there with
the latest from Whitehaven in Cumbria
and hopefully we'll be able to let you
know the government's decision in
tomorrow's show so do join us for that I
mean while the G7 has made uh 15 billion
dollar offer to Vietnam in order to
speed up his transition away from coal
Vietnam which is among the world's top
20 coal users had been due to sign up
for the so-called Just Energy transition
partnership with G7 Nations at the
global cop 27 climate Summits last month
but talks broke off before the meeting
a report by the climate change committee
has warned that what it calls Scotland's
trend of failure in meeting targets to
reduce greenhouse gas emissions will
continue without urgent and strong
action
in its latest reports to discussions
Parliament the CCC noted that Scotland
had missed seven of 11 targets to date
the country's Net Zero secretary Michael
Madison said that the government was
actively considering the ccc's advice
alongside work already started to
prepare a new climate change plan
covering the period to 2040.
person and the U.S have struck a deal to
ensure liquefied natural gas which is
mostly obtained through fracking keeps
flowing into the UK next year well that
agreement will ensure at least nine to
ten billion cubic meters of American LNG
is delivered to the UK over the next
year well that's more than double the
amount exported back in 2021 in the
government's effort to underpin energy
supplies threatened by Russia's war in
Ukraine energy bodies have criticized
The increased Reliance on LNG though
with its higher carbon footprint and
costs alongside the growing Reliance on
overseas vendors compared to
domestically produced gas
LNG is around four times as carbon
intensive as UK Shale making it
considerably less appealing than
domestic supplies
now the U.N Secretary General says that
Humanity has become a weapon of mass
extinction and called in governments to
end the orgy of Destruction Antonio
Gutierrez was speaking at the opening
ceremony of cop 15 the biodiversity
Summit in Montreal which follows hard on
the hills of last month's climate
conference cop 27 which of course if you
remember took part place in sharmil's
shake the host country's prime minister
Justin Trudeau has urged countries to
sign up to a Target to conserve 30
percent of the planets for future for
nature use our science correspondent
Thomas Moore has the this report
we've got a pair out here which are
around this morning called by Brook and
keenel so they're one of our regular
pairs at slimbridge nature reserving
gloucestershire the Buick swans are back
from their summer in Siberia but each
year there are fewer the European
population has slumped by a third in two
decades the wetlands are being drained
for things like agriculture for other
land use so there's lots and lots of
pressures where people are wanting to
use that available space but wetlands
are some of the most biodiverse habitats
on Earth they can hold lots and lots of
wildlife not just our Buick swans but
also suspicious all over the world
across the planet the abundance and
variety of life is in free fall one
million species are threatened with
Extinction and the United Nations is
holding the nature equivalent of the
recent cop 27 climate Summit in the hope
of thrashing out a global blueprint to
reverse the decline
this isn't just about the loss of a few
cute animals they are a symptom of an
underlying crisis in natural habitats
that are sick and shrinking and we
depend on them too for our life support
the summit called cop15 will seek Global
agreement to reverse the loss of nature
by 2030 conservation groups want an end
to agricultural subsidies that encourage
deforestation and a reduction in the use
of pesticides to reverse the crash in
insect numbers we are treating nature
like a toilet and ultimately we are
committing suicide by proxy
because the loss of Nature and
biodiversity comes with a steep human
cost
a cost we measure in lost jobs anger
diseases and deaths Britain is one of
the most nature depleted countries on
the planet
uncertainty of the government's
commitment to environmental regulations
hasn't built confidence that ministers
care but one Insider a former green
campaigner insists things are changing
there are lots of really good things
happening lots of policies still to come
through this is now the moment when we
have to start getting serious it's all
very well to have these targets and have
the policies if they don't make a
difference on the ground then there's
every good reason to ask questions this
Summit will determine the health of
nature for centuries to come but
conservationists warn time is running
out right now the planet is experiencing
the largest loss of life since the
dinosaurs
Thomas More Sky News in gloucestershire
and we'll be keeping you right up to
date with what's happening at cop15
throughout this week and next and also
on tomorrow's show we're hoping to speak
to a delegate live in Montreal well that
is it from us but just a reminder that
you can watch Tom heaps climate show
that will be on Saturdays and Sundays at
3 30 in the afternoon or at 7 30 in the
evening and of course if you have any
questions about the climate change that
you once answered very simple just send
all of your questions through to us
using that QR code which is on your
screen right now we will try to answer
as many as we can on Tom's show
and that is it from me for now thank you
for watching have a lovely day bye for
now